I've been using the LMNT because the sodium, my sodium has been low and has helped it
get back up.
Yes, so if your blood sodium is low, which can be, you know, you can have issues with blood
sodium for different reasons, and then you need to be taking a sodium product.
So then using electrolytes would be fine.
And those are good, I mean, they're not the designs for health, but aren't any better
than that.
So, absolutely, so why would a person have low sodium, a person have low sodium because
of medication, they're taking different medications can affect sodium levels because it affects
a hormone that causes you to spill sodium into your urine and you end up peeing out all your
sodium.
Adrenal fatigue can cause low sodium, other, if you have excess adema, you're going to
have low sodium because your sodium is going to go into your adema, taking the diuretic
is going to cause low sodium, and things like addison's disease, which is a disease of
de-adrenal glands, it's going to cause low sodium too.